have you ever walked home at night with
your keys between your fingers listen
over your shoulder for footsteps when
you enter a public restroom smile at
someone who frightens you because maybe
if you're nice enough maybe they won't
actually hurt you
hi look I read all the coverage what's
your name
mr. Kona Haggerty I'm safe now the
rescue the child I don't know what
you're talking about but whoever you're
looking for it isn't me any questions
about your assignments your grades as
Max my GA I know there's something
happened to you maybe I'll tell you
about it sometime what are you doing
tonight I mean working there to O'Shea's
grab a drink that sounds nice maybe
somebody's pulling a harmless prank
either way you're fine someone's trying
to to do what I'm telling you someone
was there
I think someone's stalking me and that
maybe Kurt put him up to it we could be
talking to Kurt he's locked up in his
cell
it isn't the professor with the pants
what do you mean before he came to teach
here he's involved in this massive
corpus
shouldn't you be studying where he
country right
you're like he can just hug it here mr.
Campbell he's the one that's been doing
all this to me
stalking me threatening me I can't eat I
can't sleep I hear footsteps
I would there's nobody there someone has
been torturing me
can you think that someone's me
Max is here thank you followed me here
would you here with me right from the
very beginning a card taught me that the
hunt was part of the thrill
you
you